thank you
[Music]
welcome back to another Splendid episode
of careful boys today we have with us
Colleen hey
hey she's back again does that mean is
that a dolphin I have no idea's height
what does that mean I don't know so
there's a question that's kind of been
going around and I want to see what your
guys's take is on it how do you split
expenses in your household when you and
your spouse are making drastically
different amounts
how would you do it if you have to
imagine but if you don't how do you
possibly split this 50 50. I could tell
you how I could tell you how we do it
okay yeah
so the way we do it Geo pays for
everything
I was very afraid of you really nice
that's cool man no we got um so we have
a a joint family account and then we
have my own personal account and then
her account like those are like the main
like checking accounts and then uh
everything that has to do with the
family so like paper towel tissue paper
and groceries yeah all that stuff uh the
mortgage or even like our car payment so
each person is like we have one car it
comes out of here but like let's say
it's a [ __ ] wants to get fancy
or some [ __ ] and like let's say
I want to buy LV purse then I have to
buy it out of my own or she wants to get
another car that's not like part of our
family thingama bobber then she goes and
buys it from her own account but all
family expenses go through the middle
one how do you decide how much money
gets deposited into that middle account
so ours would give us exact numbers so
ours it's actually pretty easy because
from the get-go it wasn't like this is
our family budget and then we kind of
contributed it was kind of like we went
with what we were doing on YouTube at
the time so for example
um we have a family Vlog Channel and we
have a me and her podcast so that income
just goes straight to this so
technically we don't contribute at all
to it and our our other incomes just pay
ourselves but like let's say one day we
decide not to Vlog or we decide not to
do a podcast then we would have to
create some sort of system where we both
like put money in okay we kind of do the
same thing
give you a personal thing too yeah we do
exactly the same setup but I end up just
paying for like utilities
on my account I don't know why
um it just ends up that way
you don't know why you can roll I think
I'm getting the in those the stiff end I
think I'm pulling the wool over your
eyes she's [ __ ] me over dude yeah
wait wait I'm gonna send her this video
you're like don't worry she pays for the
the gas I pay for the electric she pays
for napkins
I pay for the gas and electric oh [ __ ]
oh damn she pays the sewer she pays the
trash
the Eight dollar uh every six months
she plays on Netflix yeah she plays
actually I pay for them don't sleep on
Netflix that's expensive I pay for
actually I'm kind of getting [ __ ] over
it you're starting to notice huh oh [ __ ]
do you want a time and place to realize
oh my God no but yeah it's pretty even I
think for the most part we have the same
size let's say you guys need to make a
big purchase yeah
um if you guys need to make a big
purchase like let's say for for you or
even for her personally is that
something where you guys gotta talk it
out like yeah I think so hey I got it
for sure I need to buy I don't know
[ __ ] dual monitors for something you
gotta like if it's for two of them if
it's for my business or whatever I don't
really I just do it oh because it's your
business because the only big purchases
I make are for my business that's about
it what if we go I'm gonna put some Jiu
Jitsu mats in the living room then you
gotta talk to her about it technically
it's my business dude I can put it up
wow and you can write off that living
room and get it right off that [ __ ]
living room little loophole yeah dude I
write off everything
no but yeah it's the way you say that
yeah I agree there yeah but yeah that's
about it I don't really buy actually I
should probably buy more stuff I think
you should buy more stuff yeah you
should buy more stuff yeah that's one of
the biggest things that I think early
tubers don't realize is if you're not
spending your money you're going to get
[ __ ] absolutely goddamn annihilated
getting annihilated right now dude well
to put it lightly well I mean and what I
mean by that is like you so you set up
like a business for your business right
like it's like like tubers usually we
have like an S corp or something like
that and then you are going to Bill all
your expenses like to your business and
if you're not buying anything with your
business uh oh like all that cash gets
taxed so like at the end of the year
then all of a sudden they're like what I
saved all this money and I owe like
[ __ ] [ __ ] tons of money
I said doofies yeah dude Big Time movie
big time yeah you can oof eat but you
can't do feet once the doofy it's over
so see a doofy it's over it is but no
for me like like me and Nikki have a
business together so it's like and
everything we basically do is together
so you know I don't really know where
the money goes
what about all the people that don't
have successful businesses with their
spouse
you you were uh
the provider mainly she was in school
right you gotta put me on blast like
that what do you mean that's good that's
good stuff yeah and then now she
like legit [ __ ] medical professional
and you lost both Studios wow so how
does that switch back and forth how does
it switch you specifically to be fair I
guess I'm glad it's out there honey yeah
dude start making that transition so how
did that how did that go did you still
was it 50 50 or is it like now you gotta
like hold your pocket or it's tough
after losing the studios and getting a
pay cut at JK News starts you know
everything's not just really down
spiraling and [ __ ]
um so uh I think yeah I'm in a fun
unique position where uh for the
majority of me and Nina's relationship
she was
um pursuing her higher education and
doing her like field work and all that
stuff
um and she actually just recently
graduated like last year and picked up a
job and started working so this is like
her first time or first year in her
career going like full-time she's always
worked and done like odd jobs and stuff
like that while going to school for for
the most part you know I was
but I would say maybe 80 plus of the
financial side of things which was you
know when you know what you're getting
into at that point in the relationship
it's fine you know like you you do what
you want to do
um now though
that we got that dual household income
Glory sorry you know what I'm saying
what like 70 30 though right yeah we're
like 73. it's not [ __ ] meant to Dent
where the [ __ ] the the white and the
blue comes out the same time there's
like this much blue and then the white
is just a little bit he invented a
toothpaste but I immediately knew what
he was talking about yeah yeah yeah yeah
where was that stored it's like the
oldest hard drive in your head it's a
good reference oh now is the perfect
time to use it yeah our audience will
totally get it
um but that is it is transitioning right
it's not like even like for somebody who
comes out of like schooling for that
it's not like you automatically you know
just make money everything's good it's
like then you know your loan starts
kicking where you have to start repaying
student loans and stuff and that's like
it's a mother a lot it's like a lot a
lot like like like whatever my school
debt was like I'm this I'm in the
[ __ ] Shadow I'm [ __ ] in Mordor
right now you know I'm a [ __ ] Hobbit
is there school payments like another
car payment or like a mortgage mortgage
oh [ __ ] just expensive bro yeah so like
you know game plan is like we [ __ ]
never ever have to fully pay it off you
know just keep it and maybe in our
lifetime some [ __ ] Joe Schmo
president is going to be like hey
forgiveness maybe you get lucky and die
young that's what a lot of the kids are
counting on
[ __ ] that was worse than bartsburg
hey dude I'm not talking about you I'm
talking about that's how our system's
set up it's like Shades man you're
looking straight at me I give dude
they'll never forgive the student loans
they're gonna [ __ ] collect them we
forgave it like it's 50 500 it's a slow
brand it's got It's gotta warm up into
it so we've also opened up you know a
joint account and stuff like that uh
right now we're just contributing
monthly to it in order to just make sure
that we do have something 50 50 yeah
yeah so so that I'm also just not like
100 like trying to like just randomly
pay for everything because I do pay for
all the subscription services and um the
bills and you know I got an Amazon Prime
account and so you know she goes crazy
on Amazon you know what I mean that
credit card and then you know that
Amazon credit card also is really good
for Whole Foods and you know they love
Whole Foods you know [ __ ]
so like yeah Whole Foods
I knew it but it is cool that now now
that she now that she makes her money
like that she like buys her own stuff
though like on her own and that's cool
hey what did she buy what do you buy
what do I buy yeah in general a bunch of
tech stuff golf stuff multi-pleasure oh
like golf right now but what about tech
stuff like what do you buy Tech wise
I have the most useless things always
because I like my cables and [ __ ] yeah
so just buy HDMI cables and dongles
[ __ ] why why Steve knows Steve
knows that I like Tech stuff yeah he's a
[ __ ] gigantic TV I do I do size of
like you know in Costco when they're
selling jacuzzis and they prop it up
looks like that
you have a big ass one right next to the
mountain dance it's [ __ ] big and he
did he did sick LED [ __ ] to his to his
room which actually made me do that to
Myra
can you stop it with the red light
please I got red lights that's the other
video okay it's actually got 16 million
colors okay Philips Hue it's really big
one of those two bro tried what size
though just like this a little light
bulb voice command all that random I
just like that type of fun Tech stuff in
my home I want to feel like I'm [ __ ]
Tony Stark in my home because when I'm
outside of my home I'm definitely not
Tony Stark I'm like I don't got no gay
ass lights like that look at your
[ __ ] truck what color lights you got
your truck
and they're yellow it's for your space
only you're not a man unless you gotta
[ __ ] bag of dongles
right now I'll tell you that right now I
got some [ __ ] like that on my backpack
yeah
dongles on this here it's a dongle again
dongles are like something I don't know
you plug it in there
it's basically an adapter someone's like
you got something but it can't plug into
that so you need something to make it
plug into this oh yeah yeah [ __ ] it I
got [ __ ] cords and [ __ ] cords in
your bag I'll get my backpack dude give
me a sec you guys should see my boxes oh
I got a whole box of this [ __ ] this is
[ __ ] solid state hard drive oh [ __ ]
how many gigs like like we don't know
it's been invented this
is a this is a terabyte and since I have
a couple of these you know how I
designate I know which one is which I
put a white duct tape and I know that's
good that was for barbells
white duct tape how much was this is
president honestly probably 500 bucks
dude
I didn't know the Headway white duct
tape dude that's how next level you are
dude all right how do you guys um see
this situation this is like one of the
kind of the situation that sparked this
question that's been going around is
there's this um woman she works in
education she makes about 60k a year and
she's about to get married to a guy
who's a doctor who makes 600 Kau he has
to pay for everything she should go like
this
I made it
told her was that so they're expecting
to they're gonna buy a house together
and what he told her is that he expects
the expenses to be split evenly between
them but he didn't give specifics so
she's kind of like what the [ __ ] does he
mean by that yeah dude she's gonna get
wrecked in the electric bow then
[ __ ] sin dude yeah [ __ ] out of here
divorce his ass for just a trash yeah
think about this [ __ ] so this cat's
making success the service fee if he's
making 600 G's a year he's going to want
to live in a bigger place and guess what
you're gonna have to cool that bigger
place down yep now you're in a situation
where you're getting all kinds of work
from all kinds of angles even you're
aware of yeah the water bill bro crazy
there's more square footage to wreck you
from different angles the [ __ ]
sprinklers yeah yeah bro water bills
heating the pool oh I don't like this
guy
and it's interesting because uh without
giving details what kind of advice would
you give a person to tell them like well
maybe there's other ways non-financially
that you could feel like you're
contributing enough to the household I
mean you could charge up the [ __ ]
price that's true or you should get a
new husband
that's not a bad idea it might be like
200 she will have 60 G's but then side
Revenue stream of 200 G's
BJ appraiser how much do you value a
[ __ ] between married couples you
gotta see her I actually answers real
answers like what you would also be
willing to pay for if there was actually
a price on it yeah every time but that's
also like that means that means no
questions asked if you pay the price
it's good to go
why am I paying the price because you
have to because it was your idea
figure it out for her because I thought
it was more of a credit voucher
situation you don't have to pay out of
pocket
when when they jump up when they do this
it's worth this this was building a
whole economy in this concept
and it goes towards the bills that she
would have had to pay for it but what do
you think Pawn Stars are valued at
well they got the brick and mortars but
they're like let me see oh whoa that's a
[ __ ] from the Civil War
that's a good one they don't do those
techniques say the Susan first don't
just say BJ
BJ Anthony so nobody nobody can put a
price on something like that huh I think
it's two I think if anyone can it's
bored so put a price just go ahead I
would say per unit I would say per
second if they're mad
and they still do it that [ __ ] is
worth two times the regular I agree and
I would pay extra I'd pay double what if
she's not good at it
at it yeah what if she's not now it
doesn't then it's already a whole
system but aren't they always mad when
they're stuck in our dip
that's true but if they're really mad
aren't they always yeah but everybody's
scowling but if they're really if
they're really mad and then they still
do it I'm like
that's a big credit right there even if
they've got that Benicio del Toro going
on yeah I love Benicio though
Big Ups okay
so
um don't you think that's sabotage
though when you set someone up to tell
them like hey I expect equal
um contribution don't you feel like
that's a little bit like uh what is it
called like a trap because you can get
mad at them from so many things and be
like I I give all the money for this
household I that's what I think he's
such a [ __ ] alone [ __ ] right because I
mean 600 versus 60. that's kind of 10x
yeah I have to get that technical about
the relationship right that's almost I
was like like imagine Steve he's like
six four right and he's like okay then
I'll reach for 90 of the things above
this line like now you're starting to
measure every single part of the [ __ ]
relationship it's so weird it sounds
just like Steve problems are gonna run
into that's how they start yeah yeah so
she gotta get a new husband because like
that patient's already won if you're
making it that vague right dude you know
what she should do actually she should
she should almost play into it too much
like to making questions manhood a
little bit like she goes and buys a
[ __ ] lawnmower and she's like guess
I'm [ __ ] Mommy the lawn and [ __ ] I
guarantee this guy can't handle that for
long probably not because she's a guy no
way yeah start doing the man [ __ ] around
the house that's like watching your mom
gutters it's like watching your mom move
your house while you're sitting on the
couch
so my wife she makes way more than me
she makes so much more than me your wife
yeah so what I do is I pay for
everything so I can hold over her head
that's smart that is really smart level
there's levels to this game do they make
more than you she makes so much more
it was an empty room so you're so your
argument point is you make so much more
money and I still pay all the bills
exactly right it's power where does all
her money go it's so power and control
that's good he barely eats
um she she saves it all but for her or
for us it doesn't matter it doesn't
matter who cares uh but the doctor he
needs to pay for everything dude who's
your favorite yeah as the guy you should
pay for most of it you make 600 and the
ratio from 600k to [ __ ] 60g right
it'd be different if she's like 400 600
yeah then it's like okay cool then we're
on equal levels every time this guy gets
a [ __ ] Amazon delivery and he opens
it up and it's like a gumball machine or
something she's gonna sit there and
slowly tally it in a little invisible
[ __ ] like white dry erase board in
her mind
[Laughter]
yeah another whatever the [ __ ] cause you
you rich [ __ ] whatever you want she's
gonna hate this girl that house is
probably filled with massage chairs and
everything just to avoid the group think
though
because we don't like that oh great
lame
let's go come on okay it's great no I'm
good
he was just joking with her she's wild
takes it to like Reddit or some [ __ ]
and then it [ __ ] blows all over and
then he's like you know what you're
whack divorce you're against the grain
thing is that he's joking
he took his glasses off for this dude
she couldn't read his cues his social
cues and his humor he's making me
nervous with that look put the glasses
back can you play the role of this guy
and say it in the way you think he said
it so that it sounds like a joke ah dude
I'm not about that life dude come on you
can step into that life you probably
just dude how many times are we sitting
here and like eight minutes of a news
article goes by and Steve's finally like
nah just kidding that didn't happen at
all it's never happened one time in the
history you know what I'm saying come on
he's not coming to this guy please God I
will come on
point though it is nice that she's a
teacher because if you're going to be a
doctor and like you say you make that
much more than your teacher wife at
least she has a noble profession yeah at
least she's not doing something like
stupid and like making no money not that
that's no money that's still a lot of
money she makes but that's stupid
teaching is stupid
this guy's such a [ __ ] [ __ ] dude
yeah he's lame bro he's lame because the
way that I would do it it's like the
minute you guys become a team it's not
really like
whatever it's like okay cool now we got
660. how do we maximize 660. it doesn't
really matter where the [ __ ] if it if
it's one dollar here or whatever over
here it's like we got 660 now how do we
plan for the future as long as he's got
the prenup you wanna you wanna know one
more element that's gonna piss you off
what uh a portion of his income is going
to his alimony from his past life
[Music]
that's a huge detail you left out
now of course why is it not on purpose
making me try to go against the grain
and get called out by Steve Green over
here when you could have just [ __ ]
said that from the beginning it is child
support is [ __ ] like five G's a month
that it brings them all the way back
down also she [ __ ] already knew that
about him and [ __ ] goes into that she
said no there you go that's how you go
against the grave come on that's how you
do it now I'm in trouble with Steve
Green you came for you no matter what
you did
foreign
[Music]